adieu mission d'information
parlementaire sur la crise ducobu 19
les députés de la majorité ont voté
mercredi pour la dissoudre
au grand dam des élus de l'opposition
revenons sur ce tour de passe-passe pour
ausculter la gestion très critiquée de
la crise du coc vide
une commission d' enquête comprenant des
députés de tous bords a été créée le 17
mars 2020 parmi elles agnès buzyn
ministre de la santé au début de la
crise ses prédécesseurs roselyne
bachelot marisol touraine
ainsi que jean castex olivier verront le
directeur de la santé jérôme salomon
mêmes l'inénarrable didier raoul tu un
premier rapport a été rendu en juin 2020
il notait que notre système de soin
avait tenu bon mais ils relevaient des
faiblesses comme l'insuffisance des
stocks stratégiques d'équipements de
protection et notamment de masques la
dépendance à l'égard de l'extérieur pour
les produits indispensables
il s'avérait critique envers santé
publique france et les ars second temps
la mission s'est dotée des prérogatives
d'une commission denquête son rapport
rendu par le rapporteur républicain eric
ciotti début décembre 2020 s'avérer bien
plus cinglant très précis lourdeurs
bureaucratiques et administratives
insuffisante médicalisation des ehpad
retard dans la prise de conscience de la
gravité de la situation
manque structurel de personnel soignant
temps perdu dans le recours aux hôpitaux
privés
il n'est pas réglé le manque de
protection des médecins de ville
l'impréparation du dépistage de masse le
retard en matière de tests non jetez
plus plus de 200 pages de critique qui
nous replonge dans les affres de 2020
les députés ont donc demandé la
poursuite en mission d'information pour
continuer à accompagner la crise et sur
la stratégie vaccinale mais les députés
de la majorité ont voté son art et
provoquant l'indignation des
parlementaires de l'opposition
damien abad président du groupe
républicain l'assemblée a évoqué un
naufrage démocratique
rick ciotti le rapporteur républicain de
la mission s'est plaint d'un coup de
force institutionnel mc ren et ses
ministres ont peur d'assumer
publiquement leur politique hasardeuse a
dénoncé jean-luc mélenchon on écoute
eric coquerel député insoumis révolté
par l'arrêt des travaux
hélas la seule mission qui avait pour
rôle de co
contrôler et de pouvoir réagir à la
gestion de la crise pas aujourd'hui et
est éliminé s'indigne dérive autoritaire
de plus en plus fortes à dire que
manifestement le chef de l'état supporte
pas que c'est les 66 millions de
citoyens français est un avis sur la
question et l'expriment
c'est un peu le symbole de monsieur
macron qui
on est obligé de supporter le fait
qu'ils aient une assemblée mais ne tient
véritablement pas lui donner plus drôle
que ça du côté de la majorité christophe
castaner le chef de file des députés lrm
a rétorqué les commission denquête
émissions d'information sont temporaires
c'est la vie parlementaire julien
bureautique président en marge de la
mission d'information estime que
d'autres commissions peuvent se servir
de la suite de la crise certes et
pourquoi pas celle ci très au fait des
tenants et aboutissants pour assurer une
continuité en mars 2020 la mission
devait examiner la gestion et les
conséquences de l'épidémie de
coronavirus qui est loin d'être terminée
alors pourquoi enterrer cette mission et
guillon qui regarder dans le rétroviseur
et identifier les carences de la gestion
étatique pour améliorer la conduite des
opérations
heureusement le cadavre bouge encore le
sénat au breuil avec la création d'une
mission d'information destiné à évaluer
les effets des mesures prises en matière
de confinement ou de restriction de
liberté
on n'empêchera pas les sénateurs de
poser des diagnostics constructif